good afternoon
good evening or uh good morning to you
depending on where you find yourself in
the world
i'm talking to you from south africa
cape town my name's james lane i'm a
front-end developer for the wool from
desktop
and working particularly with the 3d
graphics
on the 3d graphics side of things
yeah and i'm excited to tell you guys
about some of the new and experimental
features we've been working on
some of those features include a new
axis primitive
and this is going to be very useful for
creating multiple customizable
axes a new polyhedron primitive we've
got
for creating arbitrary polyhedra
and to create these with holes as well
and
also about an advanced
or a prototype to help with ray tracing
your 3d graphics
and which can is a step towards more
photorealistic
rendering so i'm going to kick off
telling you a little bit about the axis
box stuff so this is a primitive for
graphics 3d
um for creating multiple customizable
axes
i've made my my code here quite small
but uh basically you'll see that the
axes sit where you would typically have
primitives like line and so on and you
can have multiple of these
just to say quickly that this is a work
in progress
some of the functionality isn't 12 2 but
it's really it's we need to still polish
and and
knock up the rough edges and there are a
few more options and
and so on that we we need to do so it's
it's more intended for v
version 13. uh as john says v13
and um so basically the
colonel team had put together spec a
huge shout out and thanks to brett
champion and his team
um and for their spec and basically this
will be used in
a variety of plots and you could also
use it i don't know if anybody listened
to the gigi plot talk
and i suspect they're creating axes as
well with lines and
placing text and so on and and this this
should make
that kind of thing a lot easier since
you can customize them
so here's a just a quick example of some
of the use cases for it like a
multi-axis plot
here you can see different axes
placed around the normal graph
and just to the left and the right there
multiple axes um they're not being cut
off by the
plot range which is one of the features
of of this new axis
primitive that you can place them they
won't be cut off by the plot range but
they will
influence the image range these are very
useful for
radial axes plots you can see these kind
of sloped axes coming in
and they can just be quickly pulled
together
like i just put a little example
together where i've got a table of axes
and that's
putting all these different axes around
so
which is is really neat um
they'll be great for parallel axis plots
like these where you you'll have you
want multiple axes for the varying
dimensions
um uh also these are great for
like ternary plots uh so you can have
sloped axes again where you can place
the axis labels on the sides on the left
right
and customize where they they placed so
let me take you into the syntax quickly
for these axes
primitives basically you'll say i want
to access you'll
give some position specification um
which will
describe how the access is placed and
you'll just specify
what's how you want the scale of that
axis
to correspond to the actual underlying
coordinate system
and the options to customize exactly
what the axis will look like
so let me kick off with some of the
simplest examples
so basically you can uh here's here's
some forms
you can say i want a horizontal axis
that's going through
y equals 1.2 so horizontal axis through
an arbitrary y value
so that would be this one up here
you can see it's again it's able to sit
outside of the plot range
without being clipped off normally if a
primitive is outside the plot range it
gets clipped
but these can extend the image range so
they can sit around a graphic which is
really useful for like those multi-axis
plots um you could also
specify that you want a vertical axis
here um i've got one going through 1.5
so if you
these top two forms are they basically
they run
across the plot range you'll see i've
put in one of our normal axes here
and these these other axes span the plot
range just like those
but you can also constrain uh
your your for instance your horizontal
axis to run from naught to one
so this example over here um we've said
the x values
of the axis will be constrained between
naught and one or you can
uh here for the vertical and i've said
they must run from -2
to 0.5 so there's it's just
some very simple ways of creating an
access quickly and in an arbitrary
position that you would like
so we also have provision for sloped
axes
um so let me let me leave it
there before i take us further so these
sloped axes
um effectively this is the same as
specifying a line you've got two
endpoints and your axes will be drawn
between those
we'll come to all the variations of
placing the scale and the direction of
that scale along those axes but
here you can see it's just a simple
sloped axes
or axes i'm just going to adjust the
lighting here slightly it's uh
shining on your bit
here we've got another form of this you
can have just like with a line you can
have
a kind of a polyline here your axis can
also be
a kind of a polyline shape
and we've also got a form where you can
specify an infinite
line through some points so you can
specify two points
and we will draw an axis between those
points and it will
run across the plot range
so we've also uh brett also uh
put in the spec that we should support
curved axes this is really cool
i used to work for a cad company and one
of the things that was very important on
their road visualizations for instance
is um to be able to draw the changes the
distances along the
road along like the center line of the
road and so on
and here we can do this kind of thing
very easily just with a
simple axis and it can be a curved axis
so that that could be a possible use
case for these
um the form for these is just very
simple
as well you just say i want an axis you
can specify what type of spline it is
b spline or bezier and then the
not points or the control points rather
of that curve and um yeah we wanted
these forms to be
quite simple uh to start with uh it's
still a work in progress but we've we've
got these
different simple forms to get things up
and going
um another form is arc this is still
under development but
you can imagine it it would probably
look like something like
the the axis around a protractor for
instance where you've got your
ticks around a circle or an
arc and its form would just be
axis arc and then your your various
arguments and those
correspond very closely to our
circle primitive next step is is looking
at how do you put a scale on this that
maps the actual axis to the coordinates
underneath it
so it's going to be axis then the
placement in the scale
um so the vertical forms like we had
like this horizontal
uh where you don't specify endpoints the
kind of the infinite ones
here what you'll do is you'll say you'll
map a value
on that that axis to the
value that you want so you'll map two of
those values and that'll give you the
range so for instance in this little
example i've said
on a horizontal axis going through
y equals 1.2 so you can see it's above
here
and i've said the value at zero where
that axis is
going through zero effectively or on the
axis
must map to 300 and the value where it
goes through
uh to 600 or at one must be 600
and you'll see it it adjusts and sets
the uh the axis labels
accordingly um where where we sp in the
forms where we specify vertices
like uh this axis form which is very
close to a line you basically just
specify the
values that you would want at the start
and end point
so so this is for linear scale um
along these graphs and we will support
log scales and and some others um
and the infinite line one will work the
same where we've specified two points
you and you specify the the value
at my first point here minus one must be
200 the value at my second point
must be in my case i set it to minus 100
and then it will put
the do the scaling along that for you
so so this is all very much for the
automatically created
axes labels and that but you can't we
will have it so you can customize
the exact ticks along the axis
um in the case of like these vertical
ones where you
you've constrained them again it's very
simple you'll just specify what's the
value at the first constraint
or at the constraint so this one's uh
you can see this axis is running from
0.8
to minus 0.5 and so the value at 0.8 i
want it to be 76
and the value at 0.5 i want it to be
53 and so you can see it's got the
corresponding values
along that cool
curves as well how do you specify the
scale along these
i've also tried to keep this very simple
um
here for the curves it's often it's
difficult to say
to specify a point on a curve like it's
easy often to know the con
you you know the control points but what
are the actual points on the curve so
here the these values correspond to the
start and the end of the curve so
this b spline curve will start uh its
values at 70
or minus 70 and then they'll range to 70
along the curve
so you've got that control of the scale
and and we are
going to provision and make support for
log scales
and arbitrary scales where
you as the user can actually specify um
how you'd like that scale to work but
that's still
a work in progress we we we're busy with
that
um second then the the plethora of
options to customize this access what do
you
like how do you do you wanted um
to to to play out so for instance here
tick lengths as usual some
simplifications that you'll have your
normal where you can specify
specific tick lengths for each tick but
here is just a simplification if you
wanted all the same tick lengths you
could just give a single value
or if you wanted to just specify your
major in your minor tick lengths
uh you could do so um
and and and just adjust it those those
values very simply
um label sides uh it's rather
we i think we should rename this to tick
label sides but you can basically say
which side
of an axis do we want our labels to be
on
um the automatic side at the moment is
as you're going from
your lower values according to your
scale to your higher ones
left would be to to the left of that and
right would be
yeah to the right of those values as you
run along that curve
from low to high value so you can say
left here
here my tick labels on the left here my
tick labels on the right
and you can see we still have some work
to tidy the placements but
it's it's underway you can also say
which side you want your ticks to be on
so here uh autumn the default and then
you could say i want my ticks on the
left my ticks on the right
and and obviously like you can you can
mix these so you could have um
you could have label sides and tick
sides and you could say
right and
right
and then they should all end up on the
same sides so
those those kind of customizations tick
label orientation this is
a kind of a new and we've we've been
just fiddling with uh where you can
actually say
uh for instance i'd like my my tick lab
normally your tick labels are vertical
um they're upright but perhaps you want
them as a long
run along a curve to
to have the same
orientation as as the curve so they
follow the axis line
or you could we we will allow you to
specify a degree or a
uh up direction so like here you can see
in this example i've said
i want these tick labels facing um in
the direction of -1
1 and then you get these oriented ticks
or rotated ticks
um access label is going to be the way
to put
a a label on on your your ticks uh you
must just excuse this uh
funny little ex the this expression
that's bringing in some of the type
setting we're still busy
finalizing and battening down the type
setting for these but
um i just put this in didn't really need
to but
to be correct i
i've just put that in here
so that get rid of that
and you'll see it still works if i take
off the
uh type kind of type setting stuff um
then styling your
your axes all the usual uh bass style
is going to be a role player
in styling and axis so you can specify
the base style default base style tick
style
will set the style of the text as as
usual
and again styling the actual actual
text here i've got a i've wrapped it in
a style box
so style orange bold
the textiles the ticks are red
and the access itself is blue and
all those combinations will will work
similarly to the way our current axes
work
and and give you just that control of
the actual styling
of the text there there are a lot of
other options that that are
are here that are coming as well um tick
label orientation
um i've mentioned um we'll be able to
allow you to decide which side of your
axis
you want your axis label to be on the
rotation of the axis label
and some more so so watch this space
this is a feature that
is
should arrive in version 13 proper but
the startings of it are in version 12.2
um so i'd love to show you more
um and more of these options but um
it's time will will catch me
so our next option is some work that you
sulu has been doing yuzulu is an amazing
developer on the front end team he does
great work
um it's just so solid and he's been
working on this polyhedron primitive
this is ready in version 12.2 um and you
can create arbitrary 3d polyhedra with
this
and the one of the cool things just like
in
i suppose the 2d equivalent of this is
is the polygon and our polygons now can
have
have arbitrary holes in them and with
these polyhedra
you can also put holes in these
and or kind of cut out
inner shapes so let's just look at a
basic single tetrahedron
example here i'm asking for a polyhedron
and you'll see the way we we specify
these polyhedra
um is by providing a set of of vertices
here you can see my vertices and
these are 3d vertices and then you
specify a set of
indices which which correspond to
to each of these vertex so like here
this is one of the faces of this
polyhedron will include vertex
it'll basically be constructed out of a
triangle
including vertex 2 3 and 4. so vertex
2 vertex 3 and vertex 4
so so that's the kind of general
format for these polyhedron you provide
your vertices
and then you specify the indices of the
so they're basically indexed
coordinates similar to our graphics
complex
the way we do things here uh one thing
to note this these polyhedron are kind
of first class objects in the front
and and and in yeah
in the software so you can do all kinds
of computation
on these polyhedron objects including
drawing them in graphics 3d
so here is is this little polyhedron
that we've got
it just consists of the four sides that
we were up there
and the faces of it are determined by
those
indices uh there's support for
multiple tetrahedra with a shared side
this is just a nice example youtube had
um these uh polyhedron uh basically work
with
the usual options that we have for
faces and so so like you can say vertex
colors and and provide the vertex colors
for the different
vertices you can provide vertex normals
you can texture these
uh and and all those other kind of
styling
operations so here's just an example
again
vertices a list of vertices then the
list
of faces
determined by the indices of those
vertices which of those vertices
will form each face and so like for
instance
uh one of the faces will be constructed
out of
vertex 2 3 and 4 and they've been
colored
green so the second vertex would be
green
the third one yellow and the fourth one
blue
so we're looking for green yellow blue
and that would be that would be
effectively this face here
and yeah so um
just as i've mentioned these are are
styled by
the various forms so you can say like
the face form must be pink the edge form
uh dashed and thick and so you can style
um yeah uh
yeah you can style these this
tetrahedron um
here's a an example where we start to
get to holes
uh excuse all the um we
basically i'm providing a set of
coordinates that i'm going to use for
this
a set of sides these are going to
determine the sides of my
cuboid that i'm going to get and then i
i ask for my polyhedron and so basically
you specify your coordinates when you
ask for a polyhedron here i've just got
it in the raw boxes form
uh your your coordinates then you
specify
the sides these indexed sides and then
we we just have just like for polygon in
2d we have a
an arrow um and then you you specify
the the holes and these are also
determined again just by invert indexed
vertices
so these are the indexes that correspond
to these vertices
and they'll be used to cut out the the
holes from this polyhedrons
so here you can see we just had a cube
and the holes basically just
they they cut out holes in the different
faces of the the cube um
here here's an example i i used
you can really see the how nice it is
these polyhedron objects are
we've we've got a cuboid and we've cut
out kind of like a rectangular cube
uh hole through the center of it and
here i've
i've just drawn i've cut i've used a
clipping plane just to cut away and you
can see inside
there's the outer shape or the outer
cube there's the inner cube
and basically together they they do they
form this
uh cuboid object um
and just a fun example
you can also have these multiple
polyhedron cubes to get all polyhedra
objects together
here's a polyhedral box but it's just
repeating the shape and the holes
multiple times using a rule so just an
example to show you can have
multi multi polyhedra multi holes
um working in these forms and i'll refer
you to youtulu for that
he he worked on this and he's done a
great job
and can can just take you through more
of the
details um i'm running out of time a bit
and now coming to a really exciting area
i've just got a a cornell box here
so i've just put in a bunch of
vertices and polygons and we've
implemented a prototype of ray tracing
so here you can see the spiky with some
shadows
and light bouncing around as opposed to
our
normal spiky with just normal
just being rasterized with our normal
rendering techniques
so ray tracing is um
a very hot topic at the moment and it's
being accelerated by gpus and
uh recently we we brought we rewrote our
renderer using metal and uh
we just bringing in some of the new
techniques there so we're leveraging
these 3d apis
and ray tracing basically brings
a metal and ray tracing bring
metal brings ray trace makes ray tracing
available for us on the gpu so this is
this can be done in in real time um
so when i evaluate that and and
uh i've rasterized that one but i'll
show you
in a moment now this is israel time um
it's just a quick note on this so this
is prototyped in
in version 12 2 so you can use it if
you've got a mac
um and we we've we've kind of just it's
a prototype so
so we we're still working on it we
haven't brought in all the
some of the the nice things but we've
kept it so that it should work on most
most mac so you don't need to i think
like it it'll work on mojave
and uh high sierra um
and and with most graphics cards so it's
basically just an in
we our ray tracing implementation is
just a basic path tracing we
tracing rays backwards from the camera
into the scene this is monte carlo light
transport that it's uh basically
simulating
um the options for ray tracing are just
very simply
simple to get ray tracing you you just
ask
for the rendering options uh to reset
the rendering method to ray tracing
and i'll come to these options that we
have with the method options to control
the number of image samples and the
ray balances um so basically
ray tracing brings makes shadows
available
so if i do
[Music]
let me do this one
okay here's a great example here you can
see shadows this is our normal rendering
you can see it's super fast it's just
rasterizing it and here
you can see it's slower as i rotate it
it's sluggish
but it is interactive um and you can
just see the
the shadows and we've got soft shadows
here
and we we're doing that we've got area
lights which is also a new feature that
comes with
array tracing and
yeah so area lights help you to create
soft shadows
you can see the light uh being reflected
off the walls so for instance lights
uh there's a light source above here uh
light hits the red wall and
reflects off it um and you can see just
see the red tint
falling on on these different surfaces
um
you can see the soft shadows one of the
cool things about ray tracing
this is mentioned in one of the metal
ray tracing talks is that shadows really
help to ground objects like here
the ball end uh looks like it's almost
floating in mid-air but here you can see
it
really grounds it and that's really use
that's a
very powerful perceptual or a useful
perceptual cue
um by so the basic syntax is like this
you can say i want ray tracing
you can specify your number of image
samples so here i'm using very few image
samples so you can see
because this is monte carlo simulation
there's the speckle in in the image but
you can
increase that to to to more
image samples and then the image becomes
a lot smoother
you can um so it one this is with one
bounce of light light hits an object and
reflects off it
um and light that
the points that um effectively
uh light doesn't uh reach or control
the points where the rays of light can't
read
bounce back to the um the light or we
can't trace them back to the light
they end up in shadow so this is just
with one bounce and you can see we get
shadows
with two bounces and we start to get the
this feeling of of the tint coming
through
and then um with three bounces
it increases more uh you can the light
bounces around the scene
more you're getting the red and the or
the green and the blue bouncing off here
and the la is the more you bounce the
light around the scene the closer you
get to
what they call global illumination um
so the scene becomes brighter as
light just bounces around it so we're
getting all those effects
are there a lot of other
visual effects that can we can implement
with this but we've just kept it kind of
small
for the moment for this prototype it
really your interest
and interest in this will drive our
development forward in this
so please like it caustics reflection
refraction motion blur
we've implemented it for transparency as
well so for instance here you can see
the light falling through the
transparent surface and you can see the
shadows here where
the surface is more opaque as in this
right example
the shadows are hard shadows they're
dark but as
for our soft shadows the lights coming
through and you can see the shadows
uh diminishing as light travels through
it we've also
um we also uh fl the colored
transparent material acts like filters
so you can see as the light shines
through here it casts like a blue
filtering effect on on the ground uh
here as well as light
travels through the red and the blue the
the tints and the colors of those
those come through as well um so just
some very important
uh quick uh things to look at floors are
really nice for these so
where you do have other objects in a
scene uh where the light can bounce off
or or where you can have the shadows
that makes a big visual difference uh
cases where
um it doesn't make a huge difference as
if they're like here
there's very little difference between
the these
the ray traced in the rasterized image
it's because there's nothing for
the lights the shadows to fall on these
uh our typical lighting includes
forward different lights so there's
lights hitting this from all over
there's nothing really for the light to
bounce off in the light with so so
scenes where light hits an object and
just bounces off
into space uh the ray tracing would be
wasted on
and yeah it would just so you can see
there's not a a big visual
improvement with ray tracing in in such
scenarios
uh i'm out of time but just a
quick note um we there's a lot to do
that we can take this forward
we would like to implement it for
windows using directx-ray tracing there
and this is accelerated on gpus
so it is interactive which is brilliant
um
and this can really uh enhance and
improve some of your
your your 3d graphics
especially for presentation they could
be great
yeah so interest in this and
feedback will help drive this forward
thank you again just so much for
listening in on my talk
i hope that this tantalizes you and um
excites you about some of the the new
features coming
um and like the polyhedron which is
already here which
uh will hel and the access box which can
uh will
be i think of great use to many of our
users
thank you so much for your time if
you've got questions please um
uh uh you can post them on on the zoom
chat
or on the talk um or after this day
as john fultz mentioned i think it's
actually ongoing now
uh there's uh an office meet up for the
front end team and
i'll be there as well and you're welcome
to bounce questions office
thank you so much for your time enjoy
the conference
bye i definitely wanted for
for windows as well okay brilliant we'll
definitely try to implement it for
windows
uh new polyhedron feature is great yeah
great stuff long awaited uh
[Music]
will it support caustics uh if for
caustics um
um we've still got some implementation
to do we've got a backward
ray tracer um but as i understand it we
we we either need a forward pass tracer
or we need like photon mapping
so uh acoustics
would like to implement uh
uh
mapping
and basically interest will determine if
we're going to
do that just for drive
but it would be a very cool effect to
implement
thanks sylvie via for asking the
question
um
and then i'm just looking for other
questions in the chat
um
very cool
it would be great if the ray tracing
system exposes interface to users so
users can plug in their own
shader program pieces uh we can look at
that
as a sylvia
we can definitely look at that um
especially with the stuff
youtu's done uh with surface appearance
um
we could we could try to bring that in
um
i can see the use for bringing this to
life in
many simulation movies that i wanted on
windows yes we will try
this is only available in mac that's
right
i'm kind of working through the
questions backwards um
it's a good choice uh
coloring's targeted and subtle not
global wl can provide that level of
customization great
if it's for axes uh yeah the
the axes can be the coloring of the axes
is totally customizable
refractive index of transparent objects
good question
um that's just uh
taking the implementation forward for
now just we just did a very simple
try to match it up to our current
transparency but yeah we should
introduce uh snell's
law for for refracting and
what we'd have to do there as well is
add a a bunch of
um of uh extra material properties as
well
um to make
the ray tracing like super work with
with that so
uh typically i think you would you'd
have a refractive index that you'd
specify
uh with your material so we will need to
implement that kind of stuff so
it's still just a prototype now but
definitely we can can look at bringing
that in
just going to questions
so coloring ticks and labels
do you expect a color function to apply
to just the curve or
also to the text and tick labels
i'll have to ah
that's brett's question good
can we specify curved axes using an
equation
i i think we could and dynamics should
will definitely feature there
so you should be able to use curved
axes
convert contour line to ticked axes
that's a cool idea
um tell you what guys i'm going to
switch over to
the office meeting and then that would
actually be a great place to
continue some of the questions um
uh thank you guys for all uh
sitting in in on this this chat
and yeah hopefully we can take these
things forward and and the interest as
well already
should be a great step at pushing these
things
forward thanks guys have a
enjoy the conference